في نوع اخر من القنابل اللي بتستخدم مواد
نوويه
وهي ما تعدش بالمفهوم الدولي انها قنابل
نوويه لان ما فيش انشطار فيها ولا
تفجيرات فيها ولا الحاجات دي هي اللي هي
القنابل يوم المنظم
اليورينيوم المنضب ده هو ده اليودينيوم
اللي بينتج
كناتج من عمليه التخصيب اليورينيوم اللي
في الطبيعه طيب هو اليوريني المنظم ده له
اي فوايد الحقيقه اولا الكميات اللي طالعه
منه في عمليه التخصيب كميات مهوله يعني
ارقام
رهيبه وفي نفس الوقت لا استخدامات حقيقيه
موجوده له لانه هيفيدني في ايه لا ينفع
كما وقود للمفاعلات ولا ولا هستفيد منه
لكن في فائده كبيره قوي ان اليورانيوم بقى
ماده عنصر معدني
المسافه بتاعته هي من اعلى الكشافات اللي
في الطبيعه كشفته يعني كميه اليورينيوم في
وحده الحجم كبيره جدا وبالتالي يفيد قوي
قوي في عمليات الاختراق ومن هنا جت فكره
القنابل يورينيوم المنظم ان انا اقدر
استعمل اصنع منها قنابل رؤوس الصواريخ
بصوره خاصه ورؤوس القنابل بتاعتها ليه
قدرتها الفائقه على الاختراق
بعدها ممكن استخدم بقى قنابل عاديه
تقليديه كيماويه الى في نفس الوقت انا
بستخدمها في الاسلحه زي الذخيره
الرصاص مثلا الرصاص بتاع اليورينيوم
المنضف ده عنده قدره اختراقيه رهيبه
طبعا مش ضد البني ادمين وبس لا ده ضد كل
العربيات المصفحه الاسلحه اللي هي من
الصعب جدا اختراقها بالرصاص العادي
اليورينيوم المنظم الرصاص بتاعه بيخترق اي
عربيه مسطحه ويوصل حتى طبعا للبني ادمين
اللي جواه من هنا امريكا بصوره خاصه هي
اللي ادخلت هذا النوع من السلاح في
ترسينتها العسكريه وان تجد عشرات ان لم
يكن مئات الالوف من هذه القنابل ومن هذه
الذخيره والى هل امريكا استخدمته في
العراق اه امريكا استخدمت هذا السلاح اللي
في مواد نوويه اللي هي اليورينيوم
استخدمته في ضرب الاعماق واختراق
الاماكن اللي تحت الارض وبصوره خاصه
الملاجئ او كما هي كانت بتتخيل القيادات
العسكريه
والحقيقه
استخدمت مش بس حتى في الحرب العراق الاولى
ده يستخدم في الحرب العراق الاولى ومحرب
العراق التانيه
وقيل ان استخدم في افغانستان هو
والحقيقه اغلب دول العالم
عندها هذا السلاح الدول المتقدمه عسكريه
وبالذات اللي عندها دول
المنظم لكن عايز اقول ايه هو هو
اليورينيوم المنظم ده هو الوحيد اللي
يستخدم طالما ان انا انا بستفيد منه
بالكثافه العاليه بتاعته طب هو اليورينيوم
الطبيعي ما فيهوش كثافه عاليه ما هو نفس
الكثافه وبالتالي ما فيش فرق ان انا اصنع
كسلاح اختراقي اليورينيوم من اليورينيوم
الطبيعي او ليون المنظم الخواص بتاعتهم في
عمليات الاختراق نفسها لانه التكاث عاليه
جدا ومن هنا جاء يمكن كلامنا المره اللي
فاتت كنا بنتكلم على
الاسرائيليه ضد ما قالت انه هو مفعل نووي
سوري وضربته وبعد كده الوكاله قالت ان لقت
يورينيوم طب ما اليورينيوم ده كان ممكن
قوي تكون من الصواريخ الاسرائيليه اللي
ضربت هذا الموقع لان هيورينيوم برضو اما
البعض بقى اللي يعني الساذج اللي بيقول لا
احنا لقينا يورينيوم طبيعي مخلق يعني
الانسان هو اللي عمله طبيعي بس يتصنعته طب
ما هو برضو اسرائيل ممكن او تستعمل
يورينيوم طبيعي مخلق اللي هي هي سواء
استعملته او استعملت يورينيوم طبيعي
النتيجه واحده انا عايز اضرب واعمل
اختراقات عميقه جدا وبالتالي اسرائيل
استخدمته مش بس في سوريا في في لبنان
في فلسطين
يعني يقيل كذا مره والحقيقه الموضوع ده
اثير كذا مره
وتشكلت لجان اللي انا برضو ما بعرفوش
دايما ليه اشمعنا يعني لجان الاماميه اللي
هي بتاعه الامم المتحده دي عمرها ما طلعت
تقرير واضح محدد دايما التقارير العائمه
العراق طبعا اللي انضرب
بعشرات ان لم يكن يعني مئات القنابل اللي
من هذا النوع ما حدش يتكلم فيها الى خيانه
طبعا استاذن حضرتك للتوضيح احنا كده قلنا
معلومتين او ثلاث معلومات المعلومه
الاولانيه ان الامريكان لم يستخدموا قنابل
نوويه بالمفهوم المعروف دوليا اللي هي
القنابل بانواعها المختلفه التي اشرنا
اليها في حلقه سابقه وانهضع رابط الحلقه
السابقه انواع القنابل النوويه اللي حضرتك
اشرت اليها قبل كده
ولكنهم استخدموا قنابل فيها ماده نوويه
وهذه الماده النوويه تحديدا هي الوقود
المستنفذ اليورينيوم المنظم الذي ينتج عن
عمليه التخصيب وانه اليوراني والمنظم ده
لا يعد بالمعايير الدوليه قنبله نوويه
ولكنه يستفاد منه عسكريا او الامريكان
استفادوا منه عسكريا لان كثافته العاليه
جدا
بتعطيه قدره على اختراق الاماكن الصعب
اختراقها بالاسلحه العاديه مضبوط معالي
الدكتور اه خليني اضيف على هل هي فقط
بتؤدي الى الاختراق اكيد لاختراق احنا
متفقين عليه انه بيؤدي الى اختراق يمكن
عشرات الامطار تحت الارض عنده هذه القدره
لكن هل هو بس اختراق اقول لا والله هي
بالاضافه للاختراق اليوريني من المنظم
اليورينيوم نفسه هي ماده مشعه بتطلع
ساعات الفا وبيتا وجاما بذات اشعه الفا
وهي اشعه مضره جدا للانسان لما بيجي يضرب
بالقنابل اليورينيوم المنظم ده او حتى
اليونين الطبيعي هو بيؤدي لدرجه الحراره
الاحتكاك
بيؤدي الى نوع من الاتربه
الاتربه
المخلطه بالمواد الدمويه الاتربه دي بيبقى
فيها جزء من اليورينيوم اللي هو مخضب ده
اللي هو مشع الناس لو استنشقت هذا
اليورينيوم ودخل جسمها بقت اشعه الفا
بخصوصا
بتؤدي الى ضرر بالغ لجسم الانسان لان اشعه
الفا دي اشعه ضعيفه جدا في الاختراق يعني
انت لو من بره كده وفي مصدر لاشعه الفا
بايدك كده بس بتوقفها لكن لو دخلت جوه
جسمك هتروح في الاورجانز
القنابل النوويه الانشطاريه لكن هي نفسها
كمان
الاتربه والغبار اللي بيطلع من اللي عمليه
الاختراق بتاع القنبله
ويستنشر بالبني ادمين قادر على انه يضر
ضرر بالغ بالانسان ما فهمتش الامريكان
وعدوا الناس بايه لما اثيرت فكره انه
استخدام اليورينيوم المنظم هل هو يعد سلاح
النووي املاك الامريكان وعده بايه وعده ان
هم مش هيستخدم ما معناه يعني مش هستخدمه
من خلالكم يعني الصواريخ دي مش هتطلع من
القواعد العسكريه الغربيه اه من القواعد
العسكريه الامريكيه الموجوده في دول اخرى
في العالم
ولكن في نفس الوقت الامريكان نجحوا انه
يوقفوا القرار هي الاسلحه دي هو الرصاص
اللي بيصنعوه الامريكان ده اللي هو بيؤدي
الى اختراق رهيب طبعا بيدمر البني ادم
ويدمر المعدات والاسلحه ده يعتبر اسلحه
تدمير شامل حتى الان نجحوا انه بدون وضوح
كده ينوعوا الموضوع هو فعلا في يعني جريمه
استخدامه ولا لا وهو بيستخدم بدون اعلان
واضح يعني من النادر ان الامريكان يعلنوا
اه انا استخدمت قنابل او اسلحه او ذخيره
من هذا ما بيقولوهاش بوضوح يعني يعني
بالمنضب حضرتك تعتقد انه رايك انت شخص من
خبرتك يعد من اسلحه الضمائر الشامل قبلها
انا في رايي اه يعدم دمار الشامل مش بجرب
طبعا قدرته الرهيبه على الاختراق يمكن
الاختراق يقول لك وانا وده فيها ايه يعني
بيخترق لكن زي ما انا قلت انه الغبار اللي
ناتج عن عمليه الاختراق دي
مضر ضرر بالغ بالناس اللي حواليها طب قبل
ما اسال حضرتك ترجع تاني قبل ما نرجع تاني
للعراق حضرتك قلت انه الميزه الاس هي في
اليورانيوم المنظم الذي ينتج عن عمليه
التخصيب اليورانيوم اهم ميزه فيه هو
الكثافه العاليه هل كنت وضحتها قبل
التسجيل ما المقصود بالكثافه العاليه اللي
بتمكنه من اختراق اجسام يعني تحت الارض او
يعني دفاعات قويه او
تحصينات او عربيات مصفحه ايه الكثافه
المقصوده اللي احنا نعرف انه
العربيات المصفحه العسكريه
ونسميها مصفحه ليه عشان تقدر تقاوم الرصاص
والضرب اللي بيحصل عليها فالرصاص جايه حتى
من كلمه رصاص اللي هو الليد الليد كشفته
حوالي 11
اليورينيوم المنضف ده كشفته تسعه عشر مقرب
على الضعف
العربيات المسطحه الجدران بتاعتها متصممه
بالشكل اللي يمنع اختراق الرصاص العادي طب
لو كان الرصاص ده مصنوع من اليورينيوم
عالي الكثافه وعلي الكشافه يعني بقصد ايه
بقصد الوزن على الوحده يعني انا النهارده
لو اللي زي ما بقول 30 مللي الرصاصه
طولها يعني لو انا باجي بشيلها هلاقيها
كتله لو معموله من اليوراني من المنظمه
يعني ضعف الرصاصه العاديه لو انا في الوزن
الضعف في الوزن فالرصاصه دي عندها قدره
اختراق لانها تقيله قويه قادره على
الاختراق فعشان كده
يعني الامريكان بداوا يعملوها بكثره
استفادوا بهذا في حروبهم وفي الغزواتهم
يعني اذا نتيجه ان كثافتها عاليه وبيكون
وزنها ثقيل فده بيديها قدره اكبر بكثير من
المواد الاخرى على اختراق الاعماق او
العربيات المتصفح